you
the gamma knife also called stereotactic
radiosurgery is a type of radiation
treatment used commonly for brain tumors
it may also be used for other abnormal
conditions of the head
the gamma knife is a non-invasive
surgical procedure that doesn't require
incisions which are cuts through the
skin instead a machine precisely focuses
and delivers about 200 beams of
radiation onto a target area inside the
head
the radiation only kills abnormal cells
while sparing the normal tissue around
them
the Gamma Knife treats small brain
tumors
blood vessel malformations and nerve
conditions that are hard to reach or too
risky to treat in other ways
the Gamma Knife head frame has four pins
or screws
after numbing the scalp the doctor will
attach the head frame with the screws
the frame prevents the head movement and
helps guide to the radiation beams with
the head frame in place an imaging study
such as an MRI or CT scan will be done
to determine the exact size shape and
location of the target to treat the
treatment team will use the imaging
studies and advanced software to create
a treatment plan
then the patient will lie down on the
Gamma Knife couch a radiation helmet
will be positioned over the head frame
the helmet contains holes that allow
only the programmed radiation from the
treatment plan to pass through with the
helmet in place the couch will slide
into the radiation unit
the procedure is silent and painless it
takes a few minutes to an hour or more
depending on the size and shape of the
treatment area
the effects on the tumour occur over a
period of time after the procedure
for more information talk to your doctor